الريش مهم جدا في
ملهى عرض بدون أحجار الراين وبدون
الترتر حسنًا ، إنه ليس كذلك على الإطلاق
تبين أنه عليك إحضار بعض الريش
لأنها حية لأنها
يتحرك بالكامل لأن هنا شفائه
الغلاف الجوي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا اسمي يقال فبراير وأنا
أنا مسؤول عن ورشة العمل المنزلية
هذا انت
منزل فبراير موجود منذ عام 1900
المكان الذي كان عليه أن يصنعه قبل كل شيء
أغطية الرأس الزينة ثم المنزل
متخصصون في الأزياء
قاعة الموسيقى التي عملنا بها
حاول الصعود
josephine baker zizi jeanmire all
هؤلاء الزملاء قد أحرزوا تقدمًا فقط
حتى الآن جلب العمال الريش
المتحدثين الذين يجلبهم حبهم للقلم
من الحياة إلى الأزياء كل شيء مصنوع ل
اليد التي نستخدمها دائمًا
أدوات منذ سنوات عندما يكون هناك
غطاء رأس بقطع 300 كم
ثلاثون راقصًا هو الكثير
العمل التحضيري
[موسيقى]
كل ريشنا يعود من التكاثر
من الطيور لأكثر من واحد لا يقتل
الطيور للحصول على أعلى
يجب أن تستخدم لإنشاء
الأزياء التي يتعرف عليها الريش
النعامة تفعل ذلك قانون الديك
دجاج غينيا ومن المهم الحفاظ على هذا
مهنة فرنسية جدا نادرة جدا
لذلك فهو مفيد للغاية هنا نستطيع
احتفظ بخبراتنا و
تنتقل من جيل إلى جيل
[موسيقى]
لرؤية إبداعاتنا على المسرح ستكون
دائما من دواعي سروري الرائع
جميلة مرة الراقصة
منفذ يسعد كل عامل ريشة
رؤية عمله يعاقب aignan في
قيمة من قبل الراقصة وهو
مكافأة هنا لكل هذا العمل في
حب شرائعه وشهوره
التحضير للزي هو جمال بلدي
[موسيقى]